hello everyone so we all know the
cryptocurrency has become a mainstream
phenomenon in the 21st century it has
become a household name in every area of
society since its inception as a
well-established notion in 2009. as we
all know the rise of additional rival
coins known as altcoins as well as the
growth of bitcoin a type of
cryptocurrency has elevated
cryptocurrency to a pedestal where it
attracts a greater tension as a result
of itself a slew of people are eager to
explore and learn more about
cryptocurrencies and invest significant
sums of money in them on a daily basis
and this is when our simply learn
cryptocurrency scale-up course comes
into the picture our cryptocurrency
scale-up course is curated by our
experts on cryptocurrency and each
lesson is well revised and designed for
a better understanding of individuals
this skill of course will help you
understand the various and unique on its
own cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
ethereum dodge coin shiba no coin nft
and solana you will explore their
individuality and how they differ from
each other also you will understand the
underlying technology of these
cryptocurrencies that is blockchain
their features and how they impact the
world in day to day life at last it will
give you a clear picture of how they
perform in crypto market and how they
are trying and succeeding in various
other platforms apart from this
this skill up course will give you free
access to its self-paced lessons this
means you can access its lessons anytime
you want all you need to do is login to
simplylearn.com and register for the
cryptocurrency scale-up course and there
you go now you can have all the
knowledge of cryptocurrency revolving
around you get certified with simply
learn today and boost your resume
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here